penang
かあの日あの自分の研究を背景まあまあ自分
あれを持っていることがこの言葉なので今日はの皆さんとちょっと共有できるとその
嬉しいなと思ってちょっと準備してきたので聞いてください
まずあのご覧の通りですねあの医療とか半導体さんこれまああのまあいろいろ校あるん
ですけれども皆さんの身近にこう感じられるものが結構あるかなと思います
でまぁ一見そのまあ医療と半導体産駒でこういう身近にあるんですけれども
言い換えるとですねまあいいか医学部と工学みたいなので全くフィールドが違うわけ
ですね
出た玉僕はこの2つのこの違うものを接続を同時に考えながらあのものを作るとか
まあ検挙するというようなことをやってましてそれがあの
ヘルスケアデバイスというものを作るということになります
でこのヘルスケア device まあ歴史は膿婆さん40年ほどでそれほど古くは
ないんですけども
例えばのこちら位の糖尿病の患者さんを使う結党時先生が行くでこれはの指に
まあ高針を刺してですねでピットそして
国病なんですけど家をとってねれいちょたまごっちみた
なのでこうピット測定すると5秒くらい測定できる
まあ結構いいもんですねでまぁこれはマーカーなさ使うんですけどもただやっぱりその
針を刺してこう
やっぱり細い道ですね患者さまへ日じゃないといけないのでこれいたいというのがあの
まずないんです
まずこれがちょっとからバットできます
けどもう一つあのちょっと話す違うんですけれども皆さんはの正
ディーエヌエーちょっとば dna 的な言われてもと思うんですがまぁ遺伝子
そういうのを読むまあ配列をチェックするですねまぁそういう dna シーケンサー
という技術があります
これはのまあ先ほどの血糖値センサーほど小さくはないんですけども8ああっで
90年にアメリカのアメリカでですねこの人のゲーム
dna の配列を全部読みましょうというプロジェクトが始まって手間世界中の研究者
がこう
混ざって集まってですねやっと正十数年常かけて2003年生ヒトのゲノムがこうほぼ
ほぼ
カー海賊されたということですただですねここで重要なのは
あのある人はある病気にかかりやすいとかダル病気になった時にある人はこの薬が効き
やすいとかっていうのはやっぱり個人によって違うわけです
でなのでまぁその個人によってどうどうかというのはいま世界中にとかを調べているん
ですけれども
その個人レベルでやはりこの配列を読むということはですね
秒6にはですねやはりその時間かかっちゃうと大変ですし
もちろんお値段的にも安いほうがいい理由なのでそういうテクノロジーの発展というの
が雨が強くの望ま
というような状況です
それでまあこういうまあ背景の中で僕があの先ほどの最初の半導体の技術を使って5倍
を何かアプローチするというのでこういう dna の配列を読む妄想ですしどう昨夜
患者さんが決定し制作のほかにもあるんですけれども
我々なりにその新しいコンセプトを持って
研究しているというようなのがまあ自己紹介です
それでじゃあこの新しいコンセプトで何かとめちゃを2つほどあるんですけども
まず1つは
先ほどあの人の下の文を読むとこれ30億円切って非常に長い音目なので一つ一つを
読んでるとやっぱり十数年かかっちゃうんです
でただですね今知りたいのはえっと自分がですねどういう病気にかかりやすいかとかね
どういうことで弾きやすいかこれ10年かかっているんですねちょっとまずいお使い物
にならないわけです
でですねなので先ほどの3導体産業とかちょっとあった
デジタルカメラですねこれらの皆さんあのまあ写真移すのに使われてると思うんです
けども
このデジタルカメラあちょっと最近ではあのまあ1000万画素
別居話でも100万画素ぐらいでもいいですけどもこの
一個一個ですね100100万の一個一個が僕の言っているこのセンサーになります
よしにデジカメにこう100万個のセンサーが入っているというそういう意味です
そこでですね例えばその30億の延期をこの100万煌2弾1000005断片化する
とそうすると300校
なるんですけれどもそれをそれぞれのセンサーで方読んで行ってつなぎ合わせてやると
掛け算で人で300かける100万で30億ですねあってますよねまあ36
要するにれ時間の一つで人のゲームが読めるという可能性があるわけです
でえっとまぁ要するにですねこのデジタルガメラが皆さんの映像を写真を写すという
ことだけじゃなくて済ん一変して皆さんのですね
から見えないね体の中の見えない個人の特徴もを映し出すことがあのできるということ
になるわけです
それでまあこんな事をですねちょっとまあ10年ほど不自身ちょっとやってまして
やってたんですけども幸か不幸かんですねまああの不幸な話をちょっと最初にしますと
個人的に前不幸か端をするとえっどこにちょっとある
a 5年ほど前ですねアメリカのヨガ
この技術を使って
次の世代の dna シーケンサーというのを製品化したわけですね
それで僕はまぁ最初に候補ンセプトを出してたんですけどもやはり製品化をされちゃう
と
まああのがやられたなと負けたと
っていう鑑賞ってマーケッター感じがちょっと今伝わらなかったかもしれませんけども
ああああまあもうねがてぃあるのでパクッと開き直ってるのもあるんですけども
を開けたと上で大きな子範囲はやはりその彼らはですね多くの人を集めたんですね
へつまり
この下濃霧の情報をよく知るまずバイオサイエンスを研究者ですねまず
でもう一つの一方では常ちょっと分野の違う半導体の控訴しを作る
たくさん作れる企業さんが入ったですねでさらにですねこの違う分野の dna を
半導体で計測する研究をするま研究者が入ってで皿
んですねそれを一気にを製品化まで持っていこうとするまあ
ベンチャー企業を作ったでさらにですね
そこにやっぱりお金が必要なので資金を出してくれ投資家さんが集まったんですねまぁ
そこはもう僕らと彼らともう全く違ったところで
で当然その
スピードがすごかったですしいろんな人を集めてまぁ異分野人集めですね強調してまー
一気にゴールに向かっていくという風の体制というのはあのー
負けたらという感じで実際にですねあのその10年かかってたものが今1週間以内で
しかもて日本円で10万円近くまで落ちてきたのでどこ
人でも寄せてを出せ乙出せそうなんですね広範囲になってきているという名のが状況
です
それでですね話題はですねまあ負けたんですねそれでまあ強調できるチームがなかった
てんてんてんというので
まぁそこでですね僕はあの強い競争心をみなさんどう思われるかわかりませんけど
次負けてられないという競争心が芽生えたわけです
て霊木ジェシーは母のやはり研究者でね特に僕自身はテクノロジーか世の中に広めたい
っていうのが待つよインセンティブとしてあるのでそれを前提にですね日本でもまあ
強調できるチームを作って
ぜひ矯正あの競争しですね次は勝ちたいというのもたんです
それで次にそのまぁちょっと注目したのが先ほどちょっと話をしたあの糖尿病患者が
使っている
血糖値戦でやっぱり針をさせて言いたい
でこれをちょっと何とかしたいなということが僕自身が思ったんですん
でえっとそこでですね痛くないず
色にするにはどうするかというので
波がにちょっと注目しましたでえっとら涙の成分はですね
血液中核を染み出してきたものなので頭ですね
を含んでますでただですね大きな問題はこう
しみ出してくるので薄まって出てくるんですね
そうするとまぁ薄いのでその間どのした海常に一緒に高感度のセンサーが必要になって
くるわけです
それでまあちょっと短く言っちゃって恐縮なんですけれども
幸いにですねこの半導体のこの技術はこの交換なんですねこれを方を持ち合わせている
これラッキーあったわけです
ですので先ほどの dna シーケンサーのように100万画素とか1000万ガスを
必要ないんですけれども
今度はですねこの半導体が持っている猫の高感度という特長を
新しいコンセプトとして上手く使っていこうと
に考えたわけです
次いで越冬まあいろいろですねその原理の検証もそうですし実験も積み重ねてきてここ
の時間空けが結構あってですねまぁ話をするとたぶん今日ここで終わらないのでそこは
勝栄しますけれども次にですねやっぱ我々考えたいのは
やはりその世界の中で
この日本の技術が3し味を取るというためにはどうするかと
先ほど負けた提供うまいネットをするかということです
でまずそのそもそもですねまあさん半導体とバイオですねそういう
違う分野に関わっているものがですからあ誰かがリーダーシップをとらないといけない
それで
そこでですね必要なメンバーを集めて強調できるチームを作るとそこが重要だとマザー
考えたんです
でまぁちょっとここに書いてありますけれどもまずその
我はのケースで行くとまぁテクノロジーはですね
広めたい
サイエンス広めたい研究者の僕がビジョンを示して
べリーダーシップをとるということを決めました
でその中でええまあこの場合購入病の患者さんなのでその患者さんのことを知っている
内科の先生
ね上でまぁこれ東大の先生ですでたと涙にフォーカスしているので
暖家の先生にも入っていただき
でさらにですねやはりその一気に製品化にしていかないとですねやっぱりお腹に出せ
ないというので
ベンチャー企業も作ろうと決意したんです
でそこにやっぱりお金が必要になってくるのでこちらのそのメインパートナーにも慣れ
ていたのいうテックさんですね
投資家さんにも入ってもらって昨年幸いにベンチャー機をつくって言っ今まだ成功か
どうかというのはぜもう少し時間がたたないと分からないんですけども少なくともです
ね
他の投資家様にも入ってきてもらったですし僕に足らない美術を持っている研究者とか
企業とか入って来てもらってて
次はですねまぁオールジャパンで猫の日本の技術が世界の中で
まあいい社長取れるんじゃないかとちょっと強く感じているところです
でしかしですねここでやっと重要なのが皆さん
インセンティブは違うわけです
要する
お医者さんはですね患者さんのためで僕は研究者とか僕自身はテクノロジを広めたい
ですね
ベンチャーと投資家さんというのはまあちょっとことがあるんですけどもお金持ってる
んですね
でみんなこい前では違うわけです
でもゴールは一つうまくいけばみんなハッピーですだから強調できる
だと思うねでただそこの協調で終わってしまうとやっぱりこう次は僕進めないなと思っ
てて
やっぱりその僕の場合ですね世界の中でどうしても1日中に写真を撮りたい
この競争しですねこれが次にやっぱり重要かなと
あの思います
でもちろんあの勝ち負け勝ち負けじゃなくてですねここだけマートルとですね
例えばその皆さんあの
サッカーのワールドカップで日本のチームが予選リーグを買ってですね
化粧到来が出来ましたとなると目が嬉しいですよね
しかも1回戦勝ったらもっとうれしいまあそれと前に出るかなというふうに思います
で最後になったんですがしつこいですけど僕研究者で世の中にテクノロジーを広めたい
と
に思っていますでもですねはただやっぱり研究だけをやっていてはダメでありその分野
を超えてね坂もビジネスのことも考えて
で必要なメンバーを集めて強調できるチームを作るというところ
をまずやらないといけないんでさらにですねやはりその世界の中でイニシアチブを取る
ためには競争する9
強いこの気持ちが重要だというふうに思います
でもちろんの皆さんは僕皆さんですぼくと立場が違うので
あの同じではないかもしれませんけどもこのまあ協調と競争って言う
まあ炎なんですかねこの言葉をですね自分自身当てはめてみて考えてみられると僕は
きっと面白いことができるというふうに思っています
ん
僕の話は以上ですありがとうございます